i started painting music just because i
would try to explain synesthesia so many
times it never quite made as much sense
to describe it verbally
so i thought it would be best just to
put it on canvas just because i've
always been an artist and it made it
much easier for people to be able to
understand it
my name is melissa mccracken and i am a
synesthetic artist
synesthesia is a neurological condition
where your brain is basically
cross-wired so certain stimuli will come
in and it'll create the wrong response
in my brain so for me that's listening
to music and it's translated into color
in my head
i'm going to paint superstition by
stevie wonder i love the song
superstition just because it's dynamic
and funky and just fun and expressive
whenever i start a piece i have to
listen to the song first to even know
what kind of colors i'd like to use
there are some songs that i hate
that i like the way that they look a
little bit like a lot of pop music and
can be pink and purple and you know just
all these fun bright colors but song's
not that good
so one of the other i appreciate it
somehow
you know you kind of really have to be
in the right vibe to be able to paint if
you're not in the right vibe you're not
going to make anything good
i think the prettiest genre of music is
jazz music i love blues and golds and
whites and it just seems very pearly and
iridescent a little bit when i listened
to etta james at last the thing that
stuck out most to me was just her voice
at the very beginning when she goes into
the atlas
and it's just a very bright and but also
warm sort of feeling very kind of
classic jazzy which jazz music generally
has a very gold and blue sort of look to
it
music has always been
a very big part of my life my older
brother is very musical and when i think
back of him playing the guitar for me i
think of the colors of what those
memories are
i was always a little disappointed
because i was never very musically
inclined it was really cool to have a
way to bring
music into you know my life in a
different sort of way
you